it's all hands and machines on Deck to
fight the latest Dengue outbreak in Sri
Lanka
almost 40 000 infections and 25 deaths
in the first five months of the year has
prompted Health authorities to focus on
stopping the spread of the virus
dozens of teams like this are scouring
the country to identify breeding grounds
for the 80s egypti mosquito the carrier
of the virus
they look for containers or surfaces
with water where mosquitoes lay their
eggs which hatch when the rains come
when warnings and fines don't work
property owners are taken to court
people are not doing the correct thing
still they are keeping the ground untidy
or breeding grounds or non potential
praying ground they are not taking our
advice further
Dr Harin Pereira told Al Jazeera that
his family practice has seen a surge in
the number of dengue patients during the
past month most cases are mild but it
can be fatal if not detected early the
platelets are responsible for the blood
clotting so once it goes to a certain
level there is a hemorrhage and there is
leaking of fluid and blood from the
liver and from the lungs as well and
then you go into shock and the pressure
drops and there are a lot of
complications that take place
entrepreneur says close monitoring is
crucial
doctors surgeries and family clinics
like these are the first Port of Call
for suspected patients but multiple
viruses causing similar symptoms is
making a clear diagnosis difficult
Professor nilika malavigay is an
internationally recognized Authority on
Dengue
she says of the four known viruses that
cause Dengue the one causing the current
surge is new to Sri Lanka which means
most people do not have immunity so when
denki 3 certainly introduced to Sri
Lanka after so many years then of course
it spreads like wildfire because there's
such a huge population who have not been
infected here at the University of Sri
Java danapura researchers are studying
how the virus has evolved
characteristics of patients who progress
to the severe stages and the immune
response of those who are asymptomatic
while the search for these Solutions
continue Health authorities will have to
continue their battle to keep infections
as low as possible
Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo